of paper this is a work in progress this
is new material
so i'm more than grateful for comments
and critique later in the q a or even
beyond that
so
my talk is titled on the concept of
history
in parentheses in foundation models
and i want to clarify what i mean by
concept of history
and what i mean by foundation models and
i will try to do this more or less in
order i will start with
what's happening i mean
so in 1940 uh german philosophy i mean
before fleeing to france uh fleeing
france towards spain and eventually
committing suicide
um but have anyone wrote a short
artistic text
known in english as theses on the
philosophy of history
now the word philosophy mind you it's
not even in the original title which is
uber
the overloaded german term
despite being a core concept of german
idealism has strong material
connotations which are raised by the use
of theses and the reference to
philosophy and benjamin's goal in the
thesis is the literal griff's arbeit so
laboriously carving out what an
established concept could mean
giving the radically changing political
conditions under which he is writing
and later translations actually use
on the content of history as the title
in the text benjamin proposes a new
quite asynchronic materialist concept of
history
fundamentally for him
history is made manufactured even and
it's not something to be discovered
to articulate the past historically he
writes does not mean to recognize it the
way it really was it means to cease hold
of a memory as it flashes up at a moment
of danger so history only comes into
existence where the present is contested
where the past becomes relevant for the
present
history is the subject of a structure
whose site is not homogeneous empty time
but time filled by the presence of the
now
and this presence of the now yet side as
benign writes in the original german is
not present it's not the present sorry
but something else a moment of immediacy
the true picture of the past floats by
and we can find that same moment of
immediacy in benjamin's other widely
read text on the work of art in the age
of its technological representability
which is from 1936.
the political potential of film then a
new and newly politicized medium
benjamin argues derives from its
potential to produce abrupt cuts
shock the viewer into a different mode
of thinking
in other words the condition under which
history becomes possible the moment of
danger
is the condition that film emulates
in both cases awareness and insight
depend on this moment of immediacy and
in both cases the moment of immediacy
must be actively captured and repurposed
for a progressive agenda for banknaming
that means a marxist agenda
before it falls into the hands of the
fascists
this does for benjamin a relation
between history is something more than
just facts about the past world and the
specific ways in which technology
mediates our experience of the present
world
crucially history manifests itself in
technology film for benjamin not as a
theme but as a specific way of seeing
and in the framework of benjamin's
thought we can just ask what is the
relation between history and technology
today what concept of history does
today's technology imply intentionally
or unintentionally
now so far you've likely heard all of
this before if you spend like more than
five minutes with a humanities scholar
in a room together so let me emphasize
that i'm interested not only in the
context of this workshop but also in my
work in general in a specific version of
this question
and this version is if we understand
computer vision so using machine
learning to look at the world as a new
way of seeing as a new medium if you
will much like film in the 1930s
what is the concept or what are the
concepts of history inherent in or
rather produced by this way of seeing by
computer vision more specifically by a
concrete class of relatively recent
computer vision models
and there's uh that means it's time to
address the second important concept in
the title of my talk
so what do i mean when i say foundation
models
foundation model you might be familiar
with this is a term introduced by a
collective of researchers at stanford in
2021 and the paper is called
on the opportunities risks of foundation
models and financial model basically
just means models that are
a very large
and beta can be used for a variety of
downstream tasks
for instance question answering and text
summarization are usually considered
distinctive problems in natural language
processing but gpt3 on the large
language model released by openai in
2020 can do both and can do also many
other things
in the visual domain which is the domain
i'm interested in
the recently released dahle 2 model has
the capability to generate arbitrary
photorealistic images from natural
language prompts such as my tile slide
which is produced here on the left and
the prompt for that is an it guy trying
to fix the hardware of a pc tower is
being tangled by the pc cables like
leokon marble copy after hellenistic
original from about 200 bc and this is
the result that you get
deli 2 can again also do other things it
can do in painting so you cut out a part
of an image and then you like replace
this part of the image and
unsurprisingly daily2 does terribly at
generating
the concept of history as a prompt and
gives you these like awful uh
inspirational signs spelling hitsy hasty
for some
reason now usually when people talk
about the opportunities and risks of
foundation models to quote the original
paper they talk about either of these
models or google's versions of these
models which are lambda and imagegen
respectively
but i want to talk first today about a
different model which has received much
less positive or negative press
which i think has much more to say in a
way about history than other models and
this model is called clip
allegedly short for contrastive language
image pre-training
and it was released together with the
first version of dali again by open ai
in 2021 and by the way when i say clip i
mean the pre-trained model so literally
the binary block released by open your
eye and not the architecture
that you know
we can generate this pre-joint model
from foundation models are famously
impossible to replicate which is a whole
other issue so the political economy so
to speak of prejudice models is
something i'm also interested in
so clip is a multi-modal model which
means that it projects images and text
into a common embedding space so
basically clip learns from images in
context for instance if you visit a
website
any image on a website will usually be
accompanied by text so this could be an
image caption
an alt text which describes the image in
case it's not loaded properly and to
accommodate people with screen readers
or simply a news article that the image
illustrates
a fully trained clip model then consists
of a high dimensional vector space or
embedding space or latent space all the
same things in which words and images
that are related are close together
similarity in other words is encoded is
modeled as spatial proximity and this is
true for all embedding models right so
be just words images and words or just
images
there's one more
brief technical aspect that i want to
mention which is that
clip is actually used in the dali
training process as a kind of advanced
perceptual law so it kind of like judges
the quality of the generated images so
they are at least partially related and
partially depend on each other
all of this means that clip while it was
designed to do image labeling
can also facilitate what computer
scientists call image retrieval so
finding specific images within an
unlabeled corpus of images based on
visual or textual problems so basically
you can give it an image or you can give
it a prompt like dally and clip will
find the image closest to the prompt or
to the image that you gave in a corpus
of unrelated images
and unlabeled images importantly
so we can ask it basically four things
for images in terms of other specific
collections of images that are
independent of the training data used to
train the model
for instance
even if there are obviously no apple
macbooks
in the collection of the metropolitan
museum in new york
and this
the examples are generated with uh a
system that i built as part of a
collaborative project with uh a german
university marvel university and the art
historical image archive that they have
there um so we used 350 000 images from
the metropolitan collection as kind of
like the data
so even if there's no macbooks in there
we can still ask clip to give us the
visually closest thing to a macbook in
the collection
and what we get is a coin that's on the
right here photograph on a well i guess
it's a space gray
to use apple's terms space gray
background position in a way that makes
the whole image similar in a strange way
to a macbook without the object in
question a macbook actually being in the
image
another example on the left there are
obviously no images of algorithms in the
metropolitan museum collection um what
would they even be right pictures of
code or what would it be
but one result of searching for
algorithm is this piece here on the left
where a broken image file a glitch.image
appears in the publicly visible
collection so this is actually on the
metropolitan website it's just a mistake
in the in the front format
let me show you one more example of
these strange correspondences that you
can have so diego velasquez's uh 1656
painting las meninas uh certainly the
most analyzed painting in the history of
art so michel foucault famously spends
like the whole introduction to the order
of things on you know talking about las
meninas uh wjt mitchell as a whole
chapter in the meta pictures book um
and that's much more scholarship and the
painting is famous
in particular for its play on
representation so the painter himself is
in the painting we do not see what he's
painting
or do we because we're actually you know
looking at the painting there's also a
mirror mirroring things in image space
there are countless interesting gaze
relations between the protagonists and
so on and so on
unfortunately
going back to generative models if we
ask delhi ii to produce las meninas for
us we just get the image on the left
here a weird like folk arts style image
of women sitting in a circle even
slightly racist i would say given that
the the prompt is spanish
um on the other hand
if we ask clip to find the work in the
collection of the museum of modern art
in new york um this is another data set
of 70 000 images that we indexed
if you ask it to find it and obviously
it's not in their collection like the
prado and madrid and we get this
photograph by roberto snow on the right
a work that clearly picks up on the same
themes as las meninas especially the
question of the gaze relation between
people in and people before the image to
use george dd brauman's term
now let me backtrack a little bit at
this point i'm not suggesting that one
model is better than the other that one
model is more interpretable than the
other that either model's
representational structure is better
aligned with our own human ways of
looking at the world
in fact picking up on our discussion of
interpretability yesterday i would argue
that foundation models are so
inaccessible at the moment
not because of their technical opacity
but because they cannot be replicated
are confined behind for-profit apis that
we have to take any kind of independent
evaluation of their capabilities
including this one with a grain of salt
what i am suggesting is that we are
looking for what
that if we are looking for what remains
of humanity of the human way of doing
things in large-scale machine learning
models the context of our inquiry
matters
in the case of daily and clip that means
that the questions that fields like art
history and visual studies ask become
relevant technically they inform not a
high-level hermeneutical analysis but a
technical close reading of machine
learning models
in other words not unlike in benjamin it
matters from where we look at the past
the past in this case is the training
data solidified in our featured model
like clip or dali
but much unlike benjamin while we can
get a better look at this past data if
we just suppose it with present data for
instance with another image collection
we can never reclaim it for the present
we can never render it into history
because in foundation models or at least
in the image models that i'm interested
in the past is irreversibly marked as
the past
this has to do with the entanglement of
style and content in these models
a trivial example is that the prompt a
cat driving a car will only actually
make the cat drive the car in a comic
world and not in a photorealistic
setting
a more interesting example is the
inability of models like dally and here
i have had to use delhi mini because
there's very restrictive content
policies that open a in x on the full
version
the inability of mods like daily to
generate color photos of fascism as
fascism is eternally marked as history
even adding keywords like 2020 does not
help here and you can actually see how
hard the model is trying right you know
to
conform to the prompt that you know it
should be color images but it's really
failing at that
let me again briefly backtrack a little
bit
i'm not suggesting that these issues
cannot possibly be solved technically
machine learning people have a great
track record
of finding ways to disentangle
representations
for instance in the case of previous
generations of generative models like
gans and i'm sure there's a way to solve
this right for the current generation of
mouse
but this i think does not take away from
the inside that for machine learning
systems history is a hard problem
that things can be temporarily so far
removed from each other that they
absolutely do not look the same but at
the same time be connected to a point
where it's almost where it almost does
look like history repeats itself is
something that cannot be taught to
machines that rely on an understanding
of similarity that is exclusively one of
spatial distance
i would just like to end with uh maybe
like a plea
for more model specificity and context
specificity
um in critical ai studies and related
disciplines
while we might not need a field called
clip studies yet we are i think at an
inflection point where specific and thus
historical critiques of specific and us
historical models might tell us more
about the place of humanity in an
ever-growing ecosystem of technical
concreteness then general critiques of
ai as a technology but i would be happy
to discuss this with you in the q a and
later thanks
okay thanks so much uh for two really um
fascinating papers about
the realities that computers can't see
they measure instead and fabian also
apologies for announcing the title of
your presentation incorrectly and
dragging you from benjamin to fukuyama
which is a real accident um
uh
yeah questions uh conor sonia
thank you both so much for
fantastic papers a brilliant way to end
um
the formal presentations of our uh
workshop
um
fabian i have a question just stating a
few that i haven't formed yet and we'll
discuss it at another time but fantastic
um
how i've had the benefit of talking to
you
before and so have thought a little bit
more about your presentation which i
really enjoyed and thought was great
i'm thinking about
how in what ways the newness
of what you're describing is really new
um because i perceived other
historical antecedents
um in a slightly different register
maybe and so i'm thinking about bernard
harcourt's work who i i've mentioned to
you in the past
who's written
he wrote an article called risk as a
proxy for race and a book called against
prediction
and he's at columbia law school and he's
working with a kind of different
literature base but i think it's really
instructive he
um he was sort of rereading for co
publicly i think you know in a group
setting which was a really interesting
project but that brought up
really interesting commentaries on
um
foucault's working in society must be
defended and elsewhere on
the
this same process right of the
determination of a political community
this is so code links it to racism right
there's a sort of the biopolitical
moment is the moment in which racism
becomes this way of distinguishing the
normal from the abnormal
so
obviously about what you're doing and
you know famously foco's methodology is
said to not see things it has no vision
in it but it has visibility so this sort
of epistemological visibility
and so it struck me that
although your language is kind of
different the process you're talking
about and what's new about this sort of
datification or
ai effication of this
is kind of a tells a really interesting
story about the way in which this sort
of political community is being produced
um similarly to the right you know the
biopolitical term
that focus talks about but in a really
unhinged free-floating way that isn't as
tied
so i wondered what it is that's becoming
invisible here
and it could be that it's a it's a power
strategy of of turning that exclusionary
tactic into something that's
far less tangible far less
seeable far less accessible
and so yeah there's a sort of
alternative historicalization there
which which puts your work into
conversation with that older sort of
process of producing political
communities in a particular
way
and then conversely to that you think
well also
um
it also mean your end questions are
brilliant like how do we how do we work
with this and at the same time it gives
a job to subjects so we can actually
interact with this through these
technologies
so it's it's sort of really i mean in a
way it's a comment but also provocation
you know to historicize this in terms of
the history of biopolitics and
and the relation between visibility
invisibility and what work subjects can
actually do on that and i think it's a
not simply a hiding or an
intensification or a worsening but also
giving a capacity to subjects to work on
this as you are and thank you
[Music]
yeah
yeah yeah sure um no thank you so much
um
i suppose a lot of this has to do with
the
disciplines that i'm coming from in
particular media studies cultural
studies i think has like an extreme sort
of financialization for representation
uh and the image and studying bodies
through sort of like
you know
um
whether subjects are there or not or if
they are there how are they figured and
so on um and in sort of folks like lisa
nakamura for instance who write some
digitizing race you know explicitly
visual methods which part of the project
that i'm trying to put forward is if
you're going to be in these disciplines
to grasp for us today is to you need to
go beyond sort of visual methods they're
not always sufficient
um
um
but i do think that you're right like
other disciplines have had grasp that in
a much better way um
to the point of sort of newness
i mean one thing that's been totally
fascinating throughout the conversation
the last few days is uh phrases like
feature extraction feature extraction is
a mode of like uh knowing the body um
this the newness like that the body
itself is like now completely fragmented
um that the subject is no longer like a
a singular subject that they're like
just fractured across systems and
processes and in a in a moment you could
be cl classified as racialized in
another moment you couldn't be that is
like quite new i think um uh and that
you know the idea that it's
this interesting reversal of things like
historically it's like the body
determines the pattern we take sort of
uh genomic phenotypical or genotypical
aspects of the body and we sort of
extract out from that and that is like a
really racist form of conceptualizing a
person to be like well you have your
skin looks this way so you have these
particular traits you're like asian good
bitter mats or whatever right the body
determines the pattern and now we're in
a different moment in which the pattern
is determining the body
um
like the behavioral patterns are
themselves like
unhinged from the body in really strange
and unusual ways so the facebook ethnic
affinities thing you know facebook were
like we explicitly we don't do race this
isn't race despite like being like
prototypical categories of like almost
like medical categories of race you know
u.s hispanic asian-american
african-american
um
because they are decoupling like race
from the body race from biology
which you know in cultural studies is
like
like yeah race isn't purely
biological but now like biology has a
lot more to say about race because of
like epigenetics and so on
um but i think that's like a really
interesting turn and like something to
grasp
um because to say sit within a racial
category that has no relation to your
body is like fascinating to me
and then the idea that you can like
shift in and out such that like you
can't evidence
your race like a racist thing that has
happened to you because they're like you
know today you are in this category but
tomorrow you're not
is like
what do we do in terms of evidencing
like historic injustice then
thanks
my question is for you as well and it
may be basic or naive but what so what i
was trying to understand so with the
facebook example you have the categories
of the hispanic african-american and
asian
and also with the analogy of the
redlining is my understanding that was
pretty intentional like we don't want
dark
colored people living in this
neighborhood
but what so what are you differentiating
between when there is an intention to
try to target like i want to target
hispanics i want to not have hispanics
or whatever look at this type of ad
or is it and do you differentiate
between that and you're working when
it's there's an unintended
development of this ethnic type of
typing can you comment on when it's
intentional and unintentional and how
your work relates to that if that
category even makes
sense yeah no no thank you so much um
yeah i think this is something i do need
to sort of like think through a bit more
what is interesting to me is the ways in
which like even
when people like computer scientists and
so on are trying to make these things
like not racist really trying really
hard like these mole can't can they just
constantly reproduce racism because
everything in like a certain colonial
context is a proxy for race
um uh like
this this sort of like race that emerges
even when you don't want it to do so
like we're supposed to be in this like
post-marketing term in which like which
produces a post like racial order so
like being asian-american is supposed to
be less important than being like
interested in cupcakes
or interested in like yoga related
content that's like verbatim categories
that facebook uses to advertise the
machine learning techniques to say like
we don't do like just basic great stuff
blunt demographics like race anymore we
use much more sophisticated techniques
to produce something like that but you
know obviously interested in
yoga-related content kind of racialized
um
it's a proxy for reading whiteness is
what i'm saying so um so
um uh yeah it's like even
it's it's this like
it's the fantasy of being post-race
and yet race nevertheless being
reconstituted constantly but being
reconstituted through epi phenomena
like you know as an epi phenomena um
in ways that are completely unintended
and yet reproduce racism nonetheless
um thank you so much tao i feel like my
question is picking up uh themes from
connell and sonia's question too so
maybe just
more of the same but um this moment when
you were talking about like the
epistemological
break
and um
you sort of answered this in your
response to connell like you're coming
from sort of a particular discipline
that is quite concerned with uh or sort
of um focused on visual representation
but you know something i think a lot in
terms of the
legal literature around the stuff is um
the epistemology of social construction
more generally so whether or not you see
the epistemological break
as applying to sort of the the visual
formulations
as opposed to data formations like is
the epistemological break happening
there or do you think it applies more
generally to sort of social construction
the epistemologies of social
construction
um because your answer to sonia almost
implied a little bit that you do think
there's something there that there's
this kind of like
one minute i'm raced one minute i'm not
that's very disorienting how am i
supposed to understand that that might
actually go to the more general
um
kind of social construction epistemology
um
where again sort of racial subordination
is structured as a sort of enduring
logic of subordination in in terms of
how we are constructed um
in our web of social relations that sort
of makes up social reality
and i guess kind of connected to that
your your um
reflection on feature extraction i
thought was so interesting because i
think my experience as a legal scholar
is that feature extraction becomes this
moment of discovery of the construction
of subordination so you like think
you're just doing a thing like oh we're
just we're just subsidizing mortgages on
the basis of home insurance rates we've
extracted a feature we don't on a priori
on its surface not a race feature
once it's enacted in the world you have
that moment of social because you've
like rediscovered what racism is which
is living in a world where social
subordination is reliably um
sort of recreating um
relations of subordination on the basis
of race
even when you've sort of extracted that
feature and so from a legal perspective
i think of that moment of feature
extraction and then the failure because
you're like once again we're doing
racism that's like the discovery of of
living in a um
maybe of not having escaped the social
construction moment so anyway that's
just like a lot out there but i'd love
to hear your your thoughts a bit more
about that yeah thank you so much i
actually was reading um marion foucating
here in healey's classification
situations the other day which i think
is a really brilliant article and it's
really like doing uh amazing work to
kind of describe the phenomena where
you're talking about um which is like
the redistribution of something not
redistribution but the recapitulation of
social orders
um by you know this and they're reading
it through uh
credit
the assignment of credit and how that
play and they explicitly are talking
about class
um and how class is now uh recapitulated
through like these classification
situations that place people in relation
to
life chances
and i think uh life chances is a really
brilliant terminology to describe what
racism is um like that it's like you
know a lot of um
uh black feminist scholars have
described like racism as a condition of
like being closer to death like a
necropolitical um construction of that
and one thing that we might be able to
do as um scholars of say critical race
humanity scholars is to look at the
orders that are being produced and how
does that help us to reconstruct like
you know to re-articulate well the
condition of race and racism is um such
that race isn't just some like
biological fact of the body or like you
know which
in cultural studies is like you know
because race is your racial identity is
a
a point of solidarity and a point of
pride and you like um are able to like
produce cultural media that is
um you know part of your identity and so
forth but also to be able to articulate
like
like you know
race is the marking of the body closer
to death
and that's what makes it pernicious
thanks so much sorry we have a couple
did machine learning people still call
feature extraction the production of
representations
is that
still eat me
thank you
yeah i think
probably making a comment that's not too
dissimilar to what's already been said
but i think the thing that strikes me as
well is that
you know i guess
i
i wonder about the um situatedness
of the observations that you're making
and there's actually both speakers in
this respect um
because they're
you're you're both in different
registers situating yourselves as
politically engaged observers and from
that perspective the epistemology of
anti-racism
um or anti-fascism you know um
has to be
included you know in the observations
that we're making and in that sense you
know that's the only way that we can
keep seeing
how race is constructed differently and
can be deconstructed and must be
deconstructed and the other thing of
course it does that
is going on with a lot of these
algorithmic systems and
in racial terms isn't just we're not you
know when we think about law right and
we think like law has a direct
discrimination that's easy to map onto a
category that's prohibited
um indirect discrimination is this kind
of second order
effect but but it always refers back to
this idea that there's a neutral
subjectivity right that just
will exist
and of course one of the important
things about anti-racism observation is
that we see that it's not just about the
the construction of a
negation but also the positive um
rarification of whiteness um which is
another side to what goes on in these
things so the the
um the valorization of certain factors
as well goes on in this and we can see
that as a production of whiteness so in
that sense
i think maybe there's no epistemological
break in the anti-racist
critique it's just that that can't be
taken for granted and of course the
problem with that is that you situate
yourself as a political observer which
means you get political resistance
but if we don't do it we see we just see
what happens right if it just is allowed
to be sort of automated or
left to the market so that's just a
comment really but i would say you know
maybe think of it as like you're you're
you're actually
repeating a really important
epistemology that that doesn't speak for
itself
maybe fabian do you want to take an
opportunity to respond to that comment
and maybe
sure uh very briefly maybe i think in
the case of
um
at least the
the models that i'm looking in in my
research uh looking at in my research
i think the the the epistemic is
inherent inherently political it really
is because you know
not only in that way that it's it's a
political as a kind of like critique
where you know you find out stuff and
then you know you consider the political
implications
but especially in this moment of
foundation models is
basically actively
acting against the interests of the
people making these models right there's
a reason why they're behind you know
paid apis and and all of that and um
it's actually also a question i always
have for people working in
interpretability um you know it just
came up yesterday a little bit
um you know whose interests are
represented in what way um in you know
the idea to make things more legible uh
in that sense but you know that's not
directly respond to your comment i
realized that but uh i think there's
much to be said about you know the
the let's say
new shapes of critique maybe that we
need to produce in the face of um also
with with like the uh you know invisible
features that are thrown at us
that you know we can read but that still
definitely represent the real world in a
certain sense so
um
thank you for both of the presentations
i was thinking about the gap between the
conclusions that both of you presented
and having this feeling that you know
both sets of observations are true
and yet you know the gap between what
you're working with is
is very apparent
and i i was thinking more about the gap
as this productive space for theory
and so my question is really for the
second presenter um and you know las
meninas really struck me as this example
maybe i'm taking it out of the seriation
that you gave us this nice
triptych in a way
but um
it's almost as if there's a gap between
the representational and the perceptual
so if you ask the program
to reproduce
the image
it fails radically it can't do it
but when you ask
the program to search and find
we know that it's much better at doing
that
and it gets closer to that perceptual
dimension
which then in a way almost becomes a
representation of self-reflexivity
and so i i guess i wanted to to hear you
fabienne say more about maybe
benjamin's essay on
um art in the age of mechanical
reproduction
and whether that provides us i don't
know if if this is a gap you see between
sort of the representational and the
perceptual it strikes me that
machine learning will of course
close that gap
right so the gap might be also precious
to this particular moment in terms of
how we think about the work of critical
theory but i have no doubt
that uh dolly or any of these programs
at some point will narrow that gap very
radically right and in that sense will
be considered successful
but i i guess i i wanted to hear more
about maybe
that space of the gap whether you see it
and and how we could work with it at
this moment
thank you i really love that question um
um but it's hard to answer
also which you know good questions
usually are
um
when i think about you know the the
notion of the gap it lets me let me say
in the context of this particular
research right
i'm thinking about you know that i'm
absolutely fascinated by
the fact that these search operations
um
necessarily
give you
a hierarchy
of results um but never an exact result
right so it's a it's a high dimensional
space full of points that represent
certain things
um but you'll never get like you know
this this one singer was like you're
always like only encircling um um kind
of you know the the best possible result
it's the same with um or it's even worse
actually or more pronounced in um in
word embeddings
where you just embed uh text basically
in a space and then you're looking for a
solution let's say to an
analogy question or something like that
and there's going to be a solution but
the solution is made up from you know
the first 10 results or something like
that because there's no exact
solution so in a sense all these systems
operate on on gaps
already and necessarily
and i think it's really interesting that
the
you know the the fact that
the retrieval approach works kind of
better i think one reason is that we
give it access
to actual artistic
artistically valid aesthetically valid
material right so the reason why we get
a result that's that's better
is because there's new new stuff that
that's being introduced and uh there's
an opportunity almost right to get
closer uh to some of the the motifs that
we're looking for this is a sorry this
is super vague um but um
yeah and that's there's another
dimension just very briefly right uh
where i see have like the gap related to
the question of the glitch this is
especially i think relevant for stuff
like ai art you know which was really
interesting for a while i would say
between 2014 and 2020 but really it's
not that interesting anymore just
because you know the models are so
perfect and you know can get these
photorealistic results it's all just you
know stacking semantics basically um
so in a sense you know as long as we
have
a gap maybe there's more opportunities
for a kind of humanist or maybe even
aesthetic uh access um to analyzing
these systems so that was a very
convoluted way of saying that i really
like the question and i have to think
more about it
um with the question to the to the first
speaker this is a bit too low but anyway
um
your talk on feature extraction was
incredibly stimulating and i was
thinking of um
uh in i'm sure machine learning
researchers in the space will will not
sort of let me lie but data repurposing
is like super common right as far as i'm
aware like you there's some researcher
who did who has this data they published
it and then you have your own project
and then you uh use the data from that
available source and then you combine it
with your project and so on so i was
thinking
it's the problem seems to be at least in
my view that's not necessarily feature
extraction but data collection itself
because i'm imagining this this yoga
example is super stimulating because
like in a in a context in some context
it could be like mutual data collection
but then if i combine it with some
other thing
it becomes
racialized right so
any attempt at collecting data depending
on the context could actually uh
be rationalized
racialized to use the term i don't know
if that's something uh you uh you
mentioned in the paper or
something that seems to be relevant and
i don't know if what i'm saying is
accurate especially from the machine
learning side but i definitely know that
data repurposing is pretty common
yes thank you
um i suppose a part of my paper is
there is so much
work done on the politics of data sets
um and a part of the project of my paper
is actually to move a little bit away
from that well not a way but just to say
like there is great great work being
done there and i think that but there's
also more work to be done
on um
how models themselves are doing a form
of like novel racialization um uh
particularly in the context in which
like i mean this interesting concept of
history it's like historical data but
when data is like constantly being
generated the
the lines of history are like much more
compressed than we would have thought i
mean oscar gandy jr like has a brilliant
sort of um interview where he's like
forget history seriously forget it
because um like the forms of racist
history that you're thinking about even
when you like incorporate them into
these new models it's producing a
different kind of order
um
an order of racism that is sort of like
not necessarily ideological but you know
like racism is being produced not
necessarily ideologically as in that is
to say with like a uh a clear regime as
to like you know i don't like these kind
of people like it's a eugenic regime
where it's like around um
uh trying to like read super mentions or
whatever but it's doing it statistically
which is a different a different order
but like it's like race is
it's like a complete ontological
flatness to data points
which still nevertheless produces a
racial order that is like a fascinating
thing to me
which has less to do with the data set
and more to do the process
oh yeah
um
those are both so great
well they were
yeah oh it goes without saying whatever
okay sorry
um but uh
this is
i'm sorry
that's a promising start um sorry is it
so sorry
i guess a question i guess sort of
thinking
both these papers you know there's sort
of
questions of bringing to light you know
representation
and questions of grounding you know like
these are sort of classic kind of
metaphors
in and and modes of thinking and
metaphor you know and phenomenology
the thing the question i'm thinking for
fabian i don't know how to express this
property you know but like
the one thing i'm thinking is is like
foundation models right you know it's a
metaphor of grounding you know there's
sort of like there's a kind of fantasy
of the earth sprung you know like
um
and like
the thing i'm thinking of you know it's
like you you you're
you you're discussing this in terms of
you know for kodian
you know sort of uh
schemer of methysis and so forth you
know
and analyzing this through benjamin i'm
wondering you know like does the sort of
idea of foundational models is i mean is
it the expression of a particular sort
of romantic
intuition you know maybe in the kind of
like
german
sense and i'm wondering is there even
like a kind of like
genealogy of
the reception you know like it's it's
always kind of operational uh image of a
particular phenomenology you know and
i'm thinking the way like heidegger
himself is kind of taken up by like
dreyfus or whatever in like computer
human interaction you know like is this
like you know it's not like a kind of
arbitrary decision
like benjamin himself is the kind of
like in the hermeneutic kind of frame
you know it's not like just you know
like you know benjamin and heidegger are
so close in so many ways you know in
like dangerous ways this is what i'm
thinking i don't know is this
is stanford you know like the
foundational model you know is it like a
kind of like
you know this like particular kind of
like uh yeah sort of phenomenological
intuition
at play uh
that you're kind of engaging with and
kind of sketching out that's kind of
crazy you know but like i don't know
like i just wonder if you have any
thoughts on that
yeah maybe maybe a
couple of brief thoughts but um i think
there's two things you're asking uh if i
if i uh
got you right that you know on one of
the question of foundation models i mean
this is a clearly ideological term right
this is manufactured to sell you
the utopia of gpt-3 running society
right
i'm exaggerating but you know what i
mean right so uh of course you could you
know go ahead and really look at it as
you know uh it may be more
ontological in a more ecological
framework and think about you know what
is really the base of these models you
know we could you know do to go you know
the very route and say okay actually it
doesn't really matter because we're
running on you know giant gpu clusters
let's look at those and not at the you
know intricacies of specific models and
stuff like that that's one thing um
but i'm not sure if there's more there
the other thing
you know you mentioned a bunch of a
bunch of theory and
the fact that you know heidegger uh at
some point in the distant past was
somewhat popular for five people in
computer science
more or less right and of course we all
wish that would happen again in a sense
but i think the question really is
don't we need like and you know i
i you use benjamin here for for a reason
but you know maybe we also need some new
some new theory right maybe the tools
and methods that we get from you know
benjamin foucault heidegger and what
have you
are not good enough anymore to talk
about these really
almost post-symbolic structures right
where you know
on the one hand nothing is is legible
it's all just like you know compressed
and garbled and on the other hand you
know especially for
large language models suddenly
everything is legible everything is
expressed in terms of natural language
right coding suddenly natural language
it's it's i mean it's the opposite
usually of natural language but suddenly
you know it's gpt free to give your
suggestions how to program um you use it
you know for whatever uh protein folding
it's all language suddenly so i think
these categories are just like shifting
and there's a i think necessary search
that uh you know we as humans have to do
in for the right ways to talk about this
yeah
a very nice
provocation to end on can we thank our
speakers for grateful and a great
discussion
[Applause]
okay that's like the end of um our
formal presentations but as we